hello everyone and welcome to round six
of this year's cutter Masters we have a
wonderful game that was also played on
board six between gukesh and Vali just
finished so I decided to show it right
away it's a really wonderful attacking
game you guys will enjoy it and a lot of
cool variations to cover plus also you
will have a nice pause the video moment
to enjoy and um I've did some
investigating and I I can't seem to
figure out what is this buzzing sound
that you guys hear because some of you
in the comments say that you can hear a
buzzing sound on my videos and some of
you say that you cannot hear them even
though some of you use headphones some
of you use normal speakers as um I I I I
think it's uh probably some sort of a
frequency that I myself don't hear and
that's why I have no idea what to fix so
I I have I have tried some tweaks so
maybe it worked now so just let me know
in the comments if you still hear the
the buzzing sound because I I I I don't
know how to approach the problem as I
myself don't hear any noise uh so that
being said let's check it out and if it
doesn't work I I will tweak tweak
something else for the next video and
also you know fix my cables maybe it
will fix itself then uh so let's check
it out uh gash has the white pieces and
he opened with C4 he goes for the
English opening but very quickly we
transpose into the sudar we have Pawn to
E6 the ainur defense to the English
Knight F3 Pawn to D5 and now Pawn to D4
we have Pawn to C5 the So-Cal sudo
tarash and C captures e captures and
Pawn to G3 Gish prepares to get to his
light Square Bishop Knight to F6 we have
Bishop to G2 and Knight to C6 we have
castles Bishop to E7 Knight to C3 and
Castle so this has all been played
before nothing new here uh Bishop to G5
and now there are uh three main ideas
here uh you could go Bishop to E6 you
could capture on D4 uh or you could
Advance the pawn to C4 this is the
second most popular continuation this is
what Vali opts for Pawn to E3 and now
Bishop to E6 we have Knight to D2 uh and
now uh there are a couple of games where
Queen to A5 was played also Knight to D7
is a nor move but here we have Pawn to
H6 and it is now as of move 11 that we
have a completely new game uh so okay we
have a trade on F6 Bishop captures
Bishop captures and now uh gcash
challenges the C4 Pawn by playing Pawn
to B3 we have captures captures and now
the real question is how to defend your
D5 Pawn okay it's defended by the bishop
and by the queen but it's the it's
attacked by the Knight by the bishop and
by the queen so V has to figure this out
as her B7 Pawn is also hanging so she
handles all of it by playing Knight to
A5 uh this defends the uh B7 pawn and
also takes away the B3 and C4 squares
from the White Queen so the White Queen
now has to step back you could also
attack the Knight but it doesn't matter
B6 will defend the Knight and now D5 is
sufficiently defended for example if
something like Rook A1 you might even
get some G5 ideas with the G4 triangle
fully control the king side but in the
game GES went for Queen to B2 his idea
is that okay if Knight to C4 is ever
played he will capture and then his
light Square Bishop will open up to
attack Black's Queen side so Queen to D7
we have Rook F to C1 and now Rook a to
C8 we have Pawn to A4 Pawn to A6 at some
point of course B5 is coming and now
Queen to A2 a a A4 Pawn has uh da Pawn
has moved to
A4 and now the D5 Pawn is again attacked
by the Knight bishop and by the queen uh
Rook F to d8 Now The Rook defends the
pawn as well and now Rook a to B1 uh
Bishop to E7 and now Knight to E2 Gish
has to figure out how to create some
chances here he does of course have some
weaknesses in Black's position but he
has the wi pieces he's playing um an
opponent who is more than 300 rating
points low rated than him so of course
you have to uh go for for the win of
course Rook captures on C1 Rook captures
on C1 and now Bishop to B4 uh nicely
developing the bishop the bishop is very
active here Knight to B3 and now Knight
to C4 uh we have Knight to F4 uh going
after the bishop here but of course you
don't want to just capture it if you
capture then F captures on E6 and she
fixes her Pawn structure so Pawn to B6
and now Knight to A1 REM maneuvering the
Knight here uh Rook to C8 and now Pawn
to H4 grabbing more space on the king
side Bishop to A3 and now Rook to C3
going for a nice Rook lift here so now
if the Knight moves of course the bishop
will hang so Bishop back to B4 and now
Rook to C2 avoiding an attempt of a
repetition with Rook to C1 so Rook to C2
right away and here Vali should go for
the passive looking Bishop to D6 but
it's actually a very active move uh this
sort of uh uh not that she should go for
but it just that it's objectively best
for example Bishop to D6 and now even
though the D5 Pawn uh is sort of hanging
you you can give it up Knight captures
on D5 you will play B5 captures captures
and now uh the the Knight can't really
move if you move the Knight to avoid um
some tactics like Bishop captures Bishop
captures and Bishop captures and G3
followed by Queen captures and D5 uh you
might move it back but then this uh
again is just perfectly fine for black
if Pawn captures then Queen picks up the
D4 pawn and if you play G captures then
even Bishop to D5 and the position is
now lost for white as you've completely
busted open the uh white king side The
Rook can easily come into the attack the
queen can come into the attack so this
would be very bad for him of course uh
so what he should do after for example
he captures on um B5 not go Knight to F4
so play something like Knight to B3 the
game continues and after let's say
captures captures uh Bishop captures and
G3 you can even go for Bishop captures
and C4 and now it's just going to be a
force to draw B captures and C4 Knight
C5 attacks the queen you give up the
bishop on G3 captures captures Rook to
G2 and now Queen captures or queen to E1
check first of course uh and controlling
this diagonal you will have sufficient
resources for a draw by repetition so
that's one way to do it she decided to
go for activity she played Pawn to B5
right away and now a captures and B5 we
have a captures and B5 and now Rook to
C1 uh with have Bishop to D2 attacking
the rook and trying to give up the uh
two pieces for The Rook here point is
that if Rook captures on C4 for example
D captures on C4 and queen captures yes
you do have two pieces for The Rook but
the uh B and C Pawn are past pawns and
this is just very very scary to play
against so instead after Bishop to D2
Rook to B1 was played and now we have
Pawn to B4 again interestingly I will
show a line as this is classical chess I
will just show a line that is really
awesome and starts with Bishop to F5 you
attack The Rook here and now look at
this Knight to B3 goes after the the the
bishop here uh Bishop captures on E3 or
you could go for uh Bishop captures Rook
on B1 and then after Queen captures on
B1 then play Bishop captures on E3 but
this is even better Bishop captures on
E3 F captures and now Bishop captures on
B1 Queen Capt and now Rook to E8 so
you're down material but you have some
excellent counterplay as you have a
passed B Pawn the E3 Pawn is very weak
the queen will also Infiltrate The King
side the G3 Pawn is very weak something
like let's say Knight C5 attacks the
queen queen comes to G4 you can play
Knight captures on D5 Queen captures on
G3 and now if Knight E4 attacks the
queen even Queen captures on H4 Queen
captures on B5 and now as you are once
again controlling this diagonal very
nicely you can even give up the Knight
with Rook to A8 going after some sort of
a Checkmate and white will not be able
to capture on C4 so you're going to play
have to play something like Knight E to
F6 with check G captures Knight E7 check
and after King to f8 even Knight to G6
check uh idea being that after F
captures you will play Queen to B4 with
check and now you want to force the king
to the seventh rank to play Queen to B7
check again not to capture The Rook
because you can capture that Rook always
uh it's basically white who is um
fighting for a draw so King to E8 you
will play Queen B5 check King to d8
Queen to D5 check and after King to E7
again Queen to B7 with check with um you
know multiple Perpetual checks uh so
this is uh definitely in the position
after uh this uh sorry uh after this
uh uh sorry sorry sorry uh here after
this Rook to B1 move uh but Bishop to F5
was not played Vally went for Pawn to B4
right away I told you the position is is
really really crazy so sorry about that
uh she went for Pawn to B4 as the one
always should she does have nice control
over the B2 Square so if she can cross
the B3 Square uh will be very nice so
Knight to B3 uh going after the bishop
once again and now Bishop to C3 uh
Knight to C5 attacking the queen and
just Queen to
D6 uh we have Rook to C1 uh and now Rook
to B8 now preparing to advance the pawn
uh okay for the moment Knight and queen
are defending it but uh now the the
white pieces are kind of stuck and can't
really move and here if you go for
Knight C captures on E6 that's actually
very much playable F captures now you
can play Bishop to H3 and black will
have to go back W will have to move the
Rook to help out with the defense of the
pawn but gkes went Queen to A7 and this
is where the game really becomes
interesting here we have Pawn to B3 and
uh now there are two moves here one that
is uh clearly winning and one that it's
winning but it's impossible for you to
calculate that it's winning or maybe
it's not for gash because there's Knight
captures on E6 and the other Knight can
also capture on E6 so Gish play Knight F
captures on E6 uh but uh winning is much
much simpler with Knight C captures and
C6 and um this is why uh B2 of course
she will play this in all the lines as
this is a hypothetical line Rook to B1
and now the uh real defense that we have
to calculate not have captures on E6 but
rather Knight to D2 this is a defense
that
um uh will not work uh in this
particular line if if this Knight
captures because uh now Bishop captures
on D5 is possible the Knight here guards
the bishop and after Knight captures on
B1 there's Knight to G5 and now how are
you defending uh look at this the queen
captures on F7 is coming if you play
Rook to f8 there's Bishop captures an F7
with check and after King h8 there's
Queen to E7 uh absolutely incredible
sacrificing the queen or you know just
uh you know completely obliterating uh
black there's nothing to be played here
if captures Knight to G6 uh a beautiful
smattered mate um uh or maybe this isn't
called a smattered mate as you know
probably a smattered mate is when there
there are pieces U right next to the
black king but also you know uh a
beautiful Knight mate so that's what
would happen if Knight C captures uh E6
was played but Gish played Knight F
captures on E6 and this is actually a
lot more complicated point being that
after Pawn to B2 that why Char played
Rook to B1 uh she played F captures on
E6 which loses the game on the spot as
she was very very low on time this move
36 and she was below 30 seconds uh to to
make time control uh but now Knight to
D2 uh is a bit different because now
Bishop captures and D5 is no longer a
move so here the win would be Rook
captur some B2 Rook captur some B2 and
now Knight to F4 uh Knight to E4 and now
Knight to D7 controlling some squares
here going after Queen to A8 with check
and now Rook to B8 will imp be
impossible as the Knight controls the B8
Square so King to H7 and now Bishop to
H3 Queen to C6 and now Knight to E5 and
now after Rook to B1 check and the King
moves let's say queen to B7 you will be
able to trade here okay black doesn't
get checkmated uh by you will capture
the D5 pawn and now the resulting end
game is winning for white because white
is just up too much material black is up
the exchange but the white pawns are are
too strong and best for black would be
in order to avoid losing the game
terribly would be just to give up um a
piece for some pawns here captures
captures and captures uh but then you
would have basically a rook and Knight
versus two Knight and Bishop three pawns
each so it's basically Rook for a knight
and Bishop which in the long run G
should win but this is with absolute
best defense and why the other Knight
capturing was better in that position at
Knight F captures on E6 but rather
Knight C captures on E6 however Vice
Char just played F captures on E6 and
now uh his position is completely
winning in inba move but it has to be
the correct move of course feel free to
pause the video and win the game for GES
while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations and spotting this
very tricky idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight captures on E6 and that's it
Checkmate is being threatened on G7 and
if Queen captures on E6 then Queen
captures on B8 comes with check and that
is enough to win the game Queen captures
on E6 was played now comes Queen
captures on B8 check King to H7 and
queen to B3 now uh going after the
bishop and this is another key uh move
in sort of Defending and attacking
because Knight to D2 with an attack on
the queen and Rook doesn't work because
after captures captures and captures the
Knight here is stuck you cannot defend
the Knight if Queen to G6 uh you will
simply play Pawn to E4 and the Knight
hangs that's pretty much it D captures
Queen captures and that's all there is
to it so in the game after Queen B3
Queen to F5 was played attacking the
rook and B1 but G is just played Pawn to
E4 and now the bishop will hang on the
next move uh this is move 40 time
control has been reached or rather after
d captures on e4 time control has been
reached uh but it doesn't help Vali as
she's now uh her her position is now
completely undefendable or indefensible
uh I don't know which one should be well
like maybe they're both correct but uh I
don't know I will check after the video
so Pawn to E3 was played and here uh
there are uh well this is a last
attempted Maybe holding if GES makes a
terrible blunder or something as okay
you're attacking F2 and you're also
attacking The Rook on B1 but GES just
played Rook captures on B2 and he was in
this position on move 42 that Vali
resigned the game uh and this as there
is nothing more to be done here and this
is her first loss of the of the
tournament so here you resign because
there's okay if you play captures on F2
then even Rook captures on F2 is a move
and white is just up a full rook and of
course if you take the Rook uh doesn't
really help you Queen captures and after
e captures Queen captures the D4 Pawn is
defended no useful checks white is just
up a full Bishop of course completely
winning for GES uh so yeah very very
nicely played very very complicated game
and like I said it's almost as if Vali
wasn't satisfied with uh with playing
for a draw against a much much higher
rated opponent uh here we uh mentioned
this where she blasted through with B5
uh that holding you know holding the
position with just doing nothing was um
a bit more precise but this can also be
played it's perfectly fine uh but you
know it's something that that you would
play if you if you're looking for more
than uh just holding the position which
uh is very commendable and is how you
should always approach playing stronger
players because if you just try to whole
and even though if the engine says like
it's the best move if you just try to do
nothing just try to hold against the
stronger player the stronger player will
always find a way to to defeat you so
activity is the way uh so yeah uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely done by GES uh here are the
standings after sorry those are not the
standings uh let me just check where are
my
standings uh I've prepared the standings
those are the opponents there we
go just for the
now why is
the very
strange oh okay I see what's happening I
see what's happening I am being trolled
by my computer all right we're very well
played sir there we
go okay so uh these are the the current
standings That 160 players uh we have uh
uh one player in the lead uh Arjun
he has five out of six oh sorry and
Naran just caught up with him also with
five out of six and then with four and a
half out of six we have Magnus Carlson
hiar Nakamura GES now with his victory
and Notre backck abdos satov I'm just
going to check real quickly as um maybe
the T table shifted while uh I was
making the video uh so yeah we do have
some others on four and a half out of
six so it's unfor for have six Magnus
Hikaru GES abdat param makulu and M kin
and David paravian on four and a half
out of six and then Anish giri with four
and a lot of players with four and so on
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh very very wild stuff here
the the sud sudo tarash uh you know uh
what are you going to do I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to danou and
I would like to uh thank congratulations
Dr shik Tucker Berkman Eddie Indus and
bullet thriller.com for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day